thank you welcome to the Steve Jobs
theater now let's talk about iPhone the
iPhone 10s is not just one but two sizes
of display the 5.8 inch and a new 6.5
inch Super Retina display is it the
biggest display ever on an iPhone now a
lot of our customers have loved the plus
size iPhones so let's put that
side-by-side you can see it's not the
same size phone with a much larger
display so what you call the phone
that's bigger than plus size but we call
it iPhone 10s max and the max is an
incredible experience there are two
super Retina displays now five point
eight inch 6.5 inch both OLED displays
both a million to 1 contrast ratio there
HDR displays they have tapped awake they
have incredible color management their
true tone display so the paperwhite
looks just right in all the different
lighting that you use it and we've
matched them to incredible sound systems
as well stereo sound better than in any
iPhone today now but the 10s should get
a wider stereo field we told you last
year that a 11 Bionic could process an
insane 600 billion operations per second
well the 812 Bionic is able to process 5
trillion operations per second
the antibiotic is a complete system on a
chip there's memory controllers storage
controllers the apple-designed storage
controller and the 8:12 Iona Canal
address twice as much internal storage
as previously so now I can up to 512
gigabytes of internal storage if you
want that's a half a terabyte on your
iPhone in your pocket that's enough for
over 200,000 photos stored on your
iPhone
it is incredible it is a remarkable new
dual camera system it has a 12 megapixel
Y camera a 12 megapixel telephoto camera
and an even more improved true tone
flash the 12 megapixel Y camera has a
new sensor a larger sensor with bigger
deeper pixels but increasingly what
makes incredible photos possible are
just the sensor on the lens but it's a
chip in the software that runs on it and
this is so true with iPhone photography
in fact when you take a photo it's
capable of doing a trillion operations
on every photo you take we have a brand
new feature we call smart HDR so let's
say you're taking a picture the camera
recognizes you're shooting a subject in
the subjects moving you go to press down
on the shutter and you get a picture
instantly
it's called zero shutter lag what the
ATL Bionic is actually doing is shooting
a four frame buffer so I can capture
that critical moment the 12 Bionic is
doing even more than that it's also
capturing secondary inter frames at the
same time and those inter frame just
shot at a different exposure level to
bring out highlight details and it's
doing more than that it's shooting a
long exposure so you can get better
shadow detail as well
and when you're taking that picture it's
analyzing all of those finding out how
to match up the best parts of each and
merge them into one perfect photo that's
smart HDR it is a breakthrough and it
makes taking photos easier than ever and
to get beautiful results this is a break
from the photography for a smartphone so
when you take the picture with portrait
mode and then you go into the Photos app
and you tap Edit you're gonna see a new
slider on the bottom it says depth yeah
someone said no get ready for this
let me pull it up you have to watch two
things at once you're gonna watch the
depth and you're gonna watch the
background you can after taking a
picture adjust the depth of field for
money let's do that again
we're gonna slide the depth of field and
watch the background as it changes the
depth of field of your photo this is
done after you've taken it this has not
been possible in photography of any kind
of camera this is something that iPhone
can now do with the power of the 8 well
Bionic chip and this is a new era of
photography one thing we've had requests
for is dual SIM capability some of you
know what this is for for the rest here
are some reasons people want dual SIM
some people want to phone numbers on
their phone and maybe a home number and
a work number some want two different
plans depending on the region in the
world they're in and what they need and
many of us like to travel and want to
keep our local phone number but may need
to get a data plan in the region we're
in so we can have access to fast data
there to do this into iPhone 10s and
10's match we've built the technology
called dsds or dual sim dual standby
this means that you have both phone
numbers there in your phone waiting to
get the call whichever one gets it
becomes the active line and the teams
work to make sure in the software but
the fact that you have two different
phone numbers is understood and you can
name them home and work primary
secondary or whatever and then
throughout the user experience you'll
see that a phone is calls coming in on a
certain line you know how to deal with
that it is incredible we are so excited
to introduce you to the iPhone 10 are
and we hope it reaches even more
customers with this amazing incredible
technology this display is really what
strikes you know it's an LCD display
that for the first time goes edge to
edge this is the most advanced to LCD
ever in a smartphone
and it's so cool we had to give it its
own cool new name it's called the liquid
Retina display it is a bigger display
than the iPhone 8 plus in a smaller
design the design actually fits
perfectly between the size of an eight
and an A+ so we think it's going to make
a lot of customers really happy and it
is an iPhone 10 experience on an LCD
display so that means you tap it to wake
it up there's no home button you swipe
up to go to the home screen first for an
LCD display it has face ID and there's a
true depth camera system the same Crudup
camera system and iPhone 10s and 10's
Macs and it has a great new camera
system as well it's a single camera
system our best single camera system
we've ever made it's a 12 megapixel
wide-angle camera the exact same
wide-angle camera in the 10s and 10's
Mac so it's our new generation sensor
that's larger with bigger pixels and it
takes beautiful photos so this was taken
from an iPhone 10 R it is stunning
incredible detail beautiful tone mapping
it's probably something you've noticed
about this photo though it's a portrait
mode photo with that beautiful
background blur take it from a single
camera system this is remarkable what
the team is able to do is combine
hardware and software to create a depth
segmentation map using the focus pixels
of neural-net software so that we can
create portrait mode photos and the
brand new iPhone 10 R yes it gets the
same advanced bokeh technology we talked
about with iPhone 10s and 10's max and
it gets depth control dynamically after
you've taken the picture so all that
breakthrough features and capabilities
that you want to write here this is a
huge day for iPhone
we now have iPhone tennis tennis Max and
ten ours thank you or iPhone 10 R will
come and six finishes and in three sizes
64 gigabytes 128 gigabytes and 256
gigabytes of storage and it will start
at seven hundred and forty nine dollars
that's less expensive than the iPhone A+
really proud of the work the team is
done on that in order it in just over a
month October 19th and they'll start to
ship a week later than that October 26th
iPhone tennis will come in three
configurations 64 gigs 256 gigs in that
new 512 gigabyte storage capacity
it starts at $999 the iPhone 10's max
same three configurations with its
largest screen larger battery we just
$100 more starting at 1099 for iPhone
tennis tennis max you can start
pre-ordering on Friday September 14 and
they'll ship a week later September 21st
we're thrilled by how much the Apple
watch is grown in such a short period of
time I mean to think this category
didn't even exist just a few years ago
and now Apple watch is being embraced by
so many people around the world Apple
watch is not only the number one
SmartWatch in the world it's the number
one watch period Apple watch series for
all starts with a stunning new display
we push the screens right to the edges
and we've curved the corners to
perfectly match the shape of the watch
and the screens are significantly larger
in fact they're over 30% larger
and we've done this with minimal changes
to the case series for is thinner so
there's actually less total volume than
in series 3 and you can customize it
with the things you care about now you
can add loved ones to your watch face
and simply tap to connect with them or
if you're traveling you can customize a
watch face to track the different time
zones or maybe you want to create the
ultimate health and fitness watch we've
added electrodes into the back sapphire
crystal and the digital crown allowing
you to take an electrocardiogram
it's it's otherwise known as an ECG and
this is the first ECG product offered
over-the-counter directly to consumers
an ECG measures the electrical activity
of the heart beat and it's used by
physicians to help diagnose certain
heart can diseases and other conditions
and so now you can take an ECG anytime
anywhere
right from your wrist you just open the
app and you put your finger on the
digital crown watch series four with GPS
starts at 399 series four with cellular
starts at four ninety-nine and we're
keeping series 3 in the line at more
affordable prices starting at just 279
you can order series four starting
Friday and it will be available the
following Friday September 21st series
three at the new prices is available
right after the show and watch OS 5 the
most advanced wearable operating system
will be available on September 17 we're
always pushing our products for and
making technology more personal we hope
that you love these new products as much
as we do